mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir voici madame et monsieur
villemin respectivement pardonnez moi
madame 33 ans et vous monsieur 35 ans
madame et monsieur villemin sont mariés
ils ont trois enfants
julien à 8 ans emeline en a trois le
troisième prénom de leurs enfants c'est
celui de grégory l'aîné qui aurait 13
ans aujourd'hui
vous le savez ce petit garçon a été
assassiné le 16 octobre 1984
il y aura donc cette année dix ans que
ce drame qui en a engendré d'autres
d'ailleurs vous a fauché pour toujours
selon votre propre expression celle que
vous en plus utilisé que vous employez
dans votre livre
dans ce dialogue entre vos deux
personnes vous dit ceci je vous cite il
ne se passe pas un mois sans que l'on
nous salissent nous aimerions pourtant
être vus tels que nous sommes et pour ce
que nous avons fait n'est plus loin vous
ajouté voilà notre histoire
c'est vers la fin du livre chacun pourra
juger si nous avions mérité après
l'assassinât de notre fils d'être aille
à ce point là fin de citation
pendant ces dix ans vous avez été au
coeur d'un vacarme médiatique et
judiciaire
vous nous avez demandé à participer à
cette émission
et si nous l'avons accepté c'est dans le
but de vous laisser vous expliquer avec
un minimum de sérénité comme nous
l'avons fait depuis sept ans avec tant
d'autres témoins d'origine et de
situations diverses dans cette émission
mais c'est aussi parce que votre
histoire nous semblait refléter certains
dysfonctionnements de la justice
et je dirais de nous la presse nous
avons naturellement à ce titre de leçon
à donner à personne
nous avons seulement le désir comme à
l'ordinaire de permettre au public qui
vous regardent ce soir de mieux vous
approcher pour travailler encore plus
sereinement
laissez-moi rappelait quelques
précautions que nous avons prises comme
à l'ordinaire il n'y a eu aucune
tractation financière pour votre
participation à cette émission
mais contrairement à l'habitude il n'y a
pas de public dans cette salle ce soir
il n'y a pas de photographe sur le
plateau de cette émission qui a
d'ailleurs été enregistrée il y à
quelques heures quoique nous disions ce
soir monsieur madame d'abord je voudrais
que nous n'oublions pas
moore votre fils grégory dont l'assassin
n'a toujours pas été retrouvé à ce jour
et puis vous monsieur villemin votre
propre cousin bernard laroche que vous
avez tué le 29 mars mars pardon 1985
pour ce meurtre d'ailleurs vous avez été
jugée à dijon en décembre dernier pouvez
vous expliquer ou rappelé plus tôt
qu'elle a été le verdict est par
ailleurs dans quelle situation
judiciaire exactement vous vous trouvez
aujourd'hui
actuellement quand j'étais condamné à
cinq ans de prison dont une avec sursis
et je suis libéré en conditionnelle pour
une durée de 15 mois un peu près jusque
juin 95
vous madame le 5 juillet 1985 vous avez
été inculpé pour l'assassinât de votre
fils grégory mais le 3 frais février
1993 c'est à dire huit ans plus tard la
chambre d'accusation de dijon a prononcé
un non lieu d'un caractère que l'on peut
souligner du mot d'exceptionnel que dit
exactement ce non-lieu mince non lieu il
enlever me moquer mais à chaque feu non
lieu charges suffisantes ils ont marqué
non-lieu pas de charge pour faire la
différence entre des non lieux où n'y a
pas assez de charges pour envoyer
quelqu'un aux assises et un non lieu ou
une personne est innocente et pour bien
marquer la différence importante qui
s'attache à se prononcer un grand
criminologue monsieur jacques les hôtes
et qui est d'ailleurs décédé il ya
quelques mois vous a écrit pour sunil et
souligner le caractère tout à fait
unique de ce non-lieu en quels termes en
gros l'at-il fait en disant qu' il
fallait que aujourd'hui enfin notre
époque il que la justice fasse vraiment
la différence entre les personnes qui
arrivaient à se faufiler au filet de la
justice et les personnes qui avait été
accusé injustement
il fallait que la justice sache faire
vraiment la différence entre un non-lieu
pas de charge et un non lieu pour une
personne réellement innocent avant
d'entrer dans la partie de ces dix
années qui a été très dur pour beaucoup
de gens à vivre est d'abord pour vous
même je voudrais que nous pussions
apercevoir la partie qui a précédé je
dirais la partie de votre rencontre et
la partie heureuse et sans nuages de
votre vie quel âge aviez-vous quand vous
vous êtes rencontrés l'année le
autre moi je n'avais pas 18 ans ça s'est
passé en mai en avril 76
et vous madame j'allais pas tout à fait
saison dans quel milieu social avez vous
grandi l'un et l'autre vous madame dans
un milieu social bourillet mais femmes
on du côté de mon papa il était bûcheron
et ma maman elle était ouvrière d'usiné
social avec des fallas heures oui
j'avais deux frères et trois soeurs mais
vous avez été élevé en lorraine non au
début famille la lorraine mais bon début
c'était la meurthe et moselle et après
les vosges manca s'est réparti dans les
faits c'est la lorraine oui et vous
monsieur dans quel milieu avez vous
grandi dans un milieu d'ouvriers le
filature mes parents qu'est ce que mon
père et ma mère ont travaillé à la
filature
j'ai quatre frères et une soeur dont un
qui était cédée le dernier oui en 1991
c'est à dire récemment c'est ça qui
étaient vos amis avant votre rencontre
car c'est votre rencontre a une
importance fondamentale évidemment dans
votre vie mais qui étaient vos amis qui
fréquentent y est vous et que s'est il
passé dès que vous vous êtes rencontrés
madisons que moi j'avais des amis de la
classe de mon âge en fait au moment où
je joue au football après une période où
je j'ai commencé à sortir
les soirées au bal au cinéma et à ce
moment là cette période c'est fait avec
mes frères et notamment bernard laroche
j'ai sorti pour nom peu près 20 ans et
demi ensemble avant de connaître
christine et vous même madame qui
étaient vos amis quelle était votre
cercle de copains des copines moi
c'étaient des amis donc du collège que
je retrouvais dans le même village que
moi et une fois que j'ai rencontré jean
marie je les ai tous quitté quoi je me
suis intégré mère chômage
oui le collège que vous avez d'ailleurs
dû quitter relativement rapidement pour
aller travailler
pour quel type de raisons économiques
économique parce que normalement elle
n'avait pas les moyens de nous faire
suivre des études donc une fois l'âge de
saison j'ai mal a décidé qu'il fallait
que j'arrête les études pour travailler
je voudrais vous poser une question qui
vous oblige encore un retour en arrière
si vous me permettez fiancée d'abord
plus jeunes mariés ensuite puis jeunes
parents enfin à la naissance de grégory
en août 1980 à cette époque de quelle
vie vouliez vous à quoi pensiez-vous
pour vous trois en fait on cherchait à
avoir un bon confort déjà pour les trois
être heureux on passait surtout à nous
quoi n'était on vivait que pour nous
qu'en étant à partir du moment où un ami
grégory on disait que pour lui quoi donc
le projet c'était nous le confort d'un
certain côté peut-être un peu égoïste
est ce qu'on veut vraiment penser qu'à
nous et puis bon moment là d'être bien
ensemble détenus possible et vous madame
même rêve même plus les mêmes rêves
oui et en plus parce que je désirais
aussi sert avoir un deuxième enfant pour
rester à la maison parce que je suis une
à caractère je suis la femme au foyer et
donc c'était la vie de famille
et bien chez soi et je veux dire tout ce
qui était autour de nous tout ce qui se
passait autour de nous on s'y
intéressaient pas du tout on avait jeudi
euros on ne cherchait pas on regarde pas
les informations en achetant aucune
presse veut dire le monde extérieur à
parme ou trois notre maison c'était ça
nous suffisait qu'est ce que ça voulait
dire pour vous à cette époque pour votre
famille pour d'ailleurs vos amis avoir
une bonne vie ça voulait dire d'abord se
hausser socialement posséder un certain
nombre de choses dans l'ordre de ce qui
était possible être tranquille avoir des
enfants
qu'est ce que ça voulait dire c'est
socialement c'est évident mais neuf fois
réussi au point de vue travail mais
bondées l'instant on a deux salaires
avoir sa maison et ne manquer de rien en
fait
avant le nécessaire et vous envisagez
évidemment de faire votre vie dans la
région des vosges où vous étiez pourtant
en 1987 vie normale a été perturbée car
vos parents monsieur villemin et
vous-même dyer avait été tourmenté par
les appels répétés d'un corbeau d'abord
je voudrais que vous nous rappeler liés
comment se manifestait cette ou ces
personnes car on ne sait pas bien
comment se manifeste-t-il ou tel tout
départ si vous voulez ça commencé chez
mes parents c'était en mai 81 c'était
des seuls à avoir le téléphone à
l'époque nous nous avons eu téléphonant
en juillet suivie à 80 et puis bon au
départ c'était une femme qui nous
téléphoner on était tous les deux et
chanter derrière un disque c'est arrivé
plusieurs fois deux fois et puis nous
avons eu cette voix rock d'hommes à
partir de novembre 80 et là c'est toi
qui l'a eu en 80 c'était christine qui
était à la maison
est-ce que vous avez pris peur à partir
de cette époque est-ce que vous avez
remarqué que quelque chose d'anormal
était en train de s'enclencher ou es ce
que vous avez pris ça pour au fond des
choses un peu gratuites
on se poser des questions quand même bon
c'était pas au début c'était pas la peur
on se poser les questions qui pouvaient
nous en vouloir on cherchait à qui vous
n'avez pu faire du mal pourquoi ou
quelqu'un que l'on tient hors des eaux
en dieu ou un apport mais je veux dire
ça nous a pas tout de suite donné la
peur c'est une fois courant 90 parce que
le jour que 80 que je les ai eus en
novembre le soir là qu'il a parlé donc
avec savoir où il ya eu la porte
la vitre de la porte d'entrée qui était
brisée de votre maison ou à la cession
de journaux ça fait pas tout mais on
n'avait pas fait vraiment le
rapprochement c'est seulement après
quand il s'en est vanté quelques mois
après qu'on a fait le rapprochement est
là qu'on a vraiment
commence à se poser des questions et
avoir peur oui vous avez bien indiqué
qu'à partir de l'automne 80 ces menaces
orale par téléphone puis ensuite une
vitre brisée s'étaient manifestés et
quand ces voies où ces personnes car
nous n'en savons en réalité rien ont-ils
cessé de se manifester
ils ont cessé en mai 83 à partir de là
plus rien plus rien oui jusqu'au drame
juste contraindre où il ya eu une
dernière manifestation dernière manif
les manifestations chez mon frère oui je
voudrais d'abord après ce rappel des
fêtes m'attarder sur les rapports que
vous avez entretenu avec la justice dès
le 17 octobre 1984 c'est à dire le
lendemain de l'assassinât de grégory
qu'attendiez vous monsieur et vous
mesdames des enquêteurs et de la justice
en général qu'elle trouve au plus vite
c'est lui qui nous a appris notre enfant
disons que nous
on était d'autant plus pressé et puis
bon entre v cloud trou avec la procédure
était langue en même temps une affaire
de famille on l'a su après c'est quelque
chose de lourd donc on était pressé on
aurait fallu deux patients en même temps
est ce que la justice a d'abord répondu
à votre attente dans les premiers jours
où les premières semaines
et petit à petit celui ci ce ne fut pas
le cas pourquoi vous at elle déçu
disons qu'au niveau des enquêteurs au
niveau de la gendarmerie ça s'est très
bien passé donc le soir un le soir même
on les a vus bon vous avez fouillé la
maison apprenez lui le capitaine cesma
nous avons été auditionnés
on a vu qu'ils bon il était d'autant
plus sensibles qu'ils avaient deux
jeunes enfants et on voyait que c'était
un homme sérieux des gens qu'on avait
confiance
et puis bon au fur et à mesure de
pierres les médias enfin c'était la
course folle donc
c'est à tout vouloir à tout prix
l'assassin au plus vite quoi
nivet les médias qui faisait une enquête
en parallèle donc c'était vraiment vous
aviez le même sentiment madame ou bien
vous étiez tous les deux prostré dans
votre douleur et au fond vous le
laissiez faire sans savoir dans quelle
situation vous vous trouviez exactement
par rapport à la justice et on le verra
tout à l'heure par rapport à la presse
les premiers temps moi je je je mendie
que la justice aille vite tout mais je
suivais je veux dire j'étais sous
calmants j'étais donc je suivais jean
marie c'est lui qui allait au rendez
vous avec les gendarmes qui posait des
questions qui demandait toujours
toujours est-ce que ça avance et tout
moi j'étais aussi impatiente qui
qu'est-ce qu'il ne sorte qu'ils ne
fassent la vérité qui nous disent qu'ils
nous l'a pris pourquoi quand vous avez
fait ça donc je dire je suivais
jean-marie mais en même temps j'étais en
retrait un peu mais quand bernard
laroche est inculpé le 5 novembre 1984
c'est à dire quelques semaines après la
mort de grégory
quel sentiment avez vous eu à ce moment
là vous avez eu le sentiment que quelque
chose de nouveau arrive est qui qui
allait permettre d'élucider des choses
est ce que vous vous souvenez de ces
sentiments avec votre recul maintenant
vingt neuf mais avec le recul mais je me
souviens de l'époque c'est à dire mais
on a été vraiment surpris si vous tirez
vous mais on était content que de
contrôler normandie enfin on avait
l'assassin et en même temps donne un
visage comme ça sur ce
de voir qu'ils cessent et ce pour nous
c'est un monstre que celui qui a fait ça
grégory et on se disait qu'une fois
qu'on aura trouvé ça va ça va peut-être
nous apaiser notre notre douleur mais
c'est encore pire vous finir et vous
madame aussi bon sur trois qui dit mais
en plus il faut qu'ils nous ont désigné
bernard laroche se poser comme question
mais pourquoi pourquoi il nous a fait ça
je veux dire on le fréquente est pas
assez on ne voyait pas souvent
donc c'était surtout la question après
pourquoi il nous a pris grégory la sq
et puis petit à petit les soupçons se
sont orientés sur votre propre personne
d'alain villemin aujourd'hui est-ce que
vous avez compris comment et pourquoi
ces soupçons contre vous sonné pourquoi
nous mais comment je pense qu'il ya eu
tout tout ce que les des avocats ont
fait après la presse a commencé à venir
donc c'est difficile à expliquer y avait
un contexte je veux dire y avait une
époque
enfin pour être simple de
l'enquète à epinal il y avait pas de
justice pour nous on avait l'impression
que ont fait en avait le droit de tout
faire pour sortir son client de prison
je sais pas si je me fais bien
comprendre tout était permis donc après
les médias auront suivi les personnes
judiciaire qui sait que j'ai dû man
speak il jouit
moi je comment j'ai ressenti c'est que
bon une fois que que bernard laroche
avait été inculpé la série qui a eu un
courant qui s'est fait surtout qu'entre
temps il ya vu les témoignages défi de
la poste et la bombe il y avait déjà
cette rumeur qui disait que c'est
l'associé ici bernard laroche est dans
le coup il n'est pas tout seul
et puis bon petit à petit en a qu'ont
lancé la rumeur et puis après ce fut un
moyen pour pouvoir sortir leurs clients
mais bon ce qu'est ce qu'est ce qui est
regrettable c'est que l'ami la presse a
suivi le juge a suivi
et quand on pense que le 24 décembre
après avoir fait une reconstitution
suivant les déclarations de christine
eddie madame villemagne a plus rien
tout est clair et le en janvier en
relance encore donc des documents aux
médias on s'est servi des médias la
photo mais on a donné des panneaux où je
vous parle en général on a donné des
documents pour relancer encore une fois
la lab sur la mère me disait le 4
février 1985 bernard laroche et remise
en liberté est moins de deux mois plus
tard le 29 29 mars vous le tué avec un
fusil monsieur villemin aujourd'hui est
ce que vous savez comment vous en êtes
arrivé là et est ce que vous regrettez
ce geste j'imagine que oui et surtout
pourquoi
déjà avant de répondre à votre question
ça peut ça pourrait paraître indécent
que je suis là pour près quatre mois de
mon procès mais en même temps ça fait
neuf ans que j'attends que j'ai un
besoin de parler la justice s'est
prononcée
c'est vrai que je ne suis pas libre je
suis en conditionnelle jusque juin mais
attendre jeu en 95 pour dire ce que je
ressens cela me paraît pas là
nécessaire d'autant que ce n'est pas la
peine de relancer les passions en un an
et demi après et puis on a fait ce livre
déjà c'est un moyen de s'exprimer
c'est une thérapie et puis j'aimerais ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que bon de
par mon acte je n'ai plus droit à la
compassion ça je sais ce dont je le
regrette et je ne cherche pas la
compression seulement ce que je voudrais
expliquer c'est que c'est ce qui s'est
passé à epinal qu'est ce qui ne l'a dit
tout à l'heure il n'y avait pas de
justice à epinal nous notre justice
était nationaux mais on l'a vu des
années après que c'est vrai il ya eu
vraiment des dérapages mais à l'époque
tout le monde monte monsieur lambert en
épingle tout le monde et moi je m'étais
rendu compte que ça n'allait pas avec
monsieur lambert j'ai fait des démarches
avaient écrit au ministre de la justice
en disant j'aimerais avoir une audience
pouvoir lui expliquer que ça n'allait
pas ça ne passait pas et puis pour venir
sur mon geste bien sûr que je reconnais
je regrette déjà la mort d'un homme
parce que ça j'aurai je vis sur la
conscience tout pour toute ma vie mais
en même temps c'est que ce qui nous
révolte quelques pendant une société une
société comme la nôtre il ya une
responsabilité collective à la mort d'un
homme et je suis le seul responsable
cette façon je n'accepte aucun problème
mais je tiens à le dire ce qui s'est
passé il ya eu il ya eu depuis le début
parce que mon christine prenait des
calmants manger rien pris et depuis le
début je me suis rendu compte que vont
c'était le avait décommandé combine des
magouilles le double langage le mensonge
et samoa jeu c'était insupportable je
vivais dans le mensonge quand vous
perdez votre enfant et puis vous si vous
voyez ça c'est pas possible
vous vous dites enfin c'est pas l'image
qu'on se donne de la justice des médias
de tous ces auxiliaires de la justice
les avocats
monsieur villepin vous êtes en prison
quand vous apprenez par votre avocat
d'ailleurs m garot l'inculpation et
l'incarcération de votre et femmes
quelle a été votre première réaction à
ce moment là en gt gt en est anéanti
c'était depuis ça faisait trois mois que
j'étais incarcéré mon seul crochet à
l'extérieur c'était christine et puis là
on a meta en prison est une chose dont
j'étais sûr comme j'étais sûre de moi
même de grégory c'était notre amour et
ça vraiment c'était c'est une injustice
matière il était tué notre enfant
deuxième fois c'est pour avoir tué
monsieur larouche vous ferez trente cinq
mois de prison au total dont 30 sans
vouloir sortir de votre cellule pour les
promenades pourquoi refusez vous de
sortir 20 depuis le joug de l'occupation
christine le 5 juillet 85
si c'était possible pour moins de sortir
donc j'étais 30 mois sans sortir oui
c'était c'était un moyen pour moi de
supporter je sais pas comment dire le
fait de sortir prendre l'air et puis
rentrer c'est encore pire si bon les
regards
non c'était terrienne est ce que la
prison d'une certaine manière monsieur
villemin vous a fait devenir brutalement
adultes c'est à dire vous à transporter
tout un coup dans un autre monde que
celui dans lequel vous aviez vécu
auparavant la prison
c'est pas la prison qui m'a changé
c'étaient des auditions que le président
simon
c'est lui qui a réussi et ça a fait une
thérapie ici au moins lui moi et m'a
questionné pendant comme christine il
m'a questionné pendant des longues
heures des jours complets complet et
parce que bon c'est vrai que quand ils
vous arrivent ça on vous tue vos enfants
on voit les magouilles et où vous
retrouver en prison alors que j'avais
jamais je pensais qu'ils allaient enfin
c'était c'était inimaginable
et puis cette attaque contre christine
son inculpation
je veux dire la prison ça ne
s'inscrivait pas ça c'est le président
simon qui m'a monsieur villemin est ce
que je peux me permettre de vous poser
une question si elle vous gêne ni
répondait pas je voudrais savoir s'il ya
un moment ou un autre dans ce tourbillon
qui vous a à la fois énormément
rapprochés l'un de l'autre on le voit
dans votre livre et nous le savons de
par la préparation de cette émission qui
était conduite par sylvie faidherbe
si à un moment ou à un autre vous avez
eu un doute sur en effet l'attitude de
votre époux aussi la question vous gêne
vous dire répondait pas non je peux vous
répondre jamais jamais jamais ô grand
n'ont jamais mais c'est pas l'amour qui
rend aveugle non on avait vécu un
bonheur avec grégory c'était s'était
fait un bide ans était évident mais plus
qu'il est vous madame est ce que vous
avez pensé que votre mari dans du fond
de la prison il se trouvait pouvait
commencer à douter de vous ou pas du
tout non plus pas qui
non pas qui douteraient de moi seul
instant et il m'avait vu avec grégory
donc l'amour que je porte à mon enfant
l'amour que je portais une vie de couple
et tout mais ce que j'avais peur c'est
que les légions d'extérieur donc je
parle avocats qui étaient dans le
dossier ou magistrats arrive à force
parce qu'ils étaient enfermés donc
général était dans un milieu aussi on
devient devient nuisible on prend les
coups et puis il faut encaisser enfants
qui s'y plient au moment où on dit bon
il faut que je sors de cette prison
peut-être seul moyen c'est de marcher
comédie j'avais cette peur qu'il arrive
à le forcer à le convaincre pour qu'ils
se mettent aussi de leur côté et puis
que qui se met contre moi c'était celle
mais venant de l'extérieur mais pas de
lui de son plus profond de lui-même
pendant ce temps là d'ailleurs madame
villemin vous êtes vous dans la tornade
de la presse vous attendez votre
deuxième enfant julien qu'est ce qui
vous a fait tenir parce qu'au fond il
était en prison vous vous étiez dans une
sorte de tornades plus ou moins
incontrôlable en tout cas de la
situation dans laquelle vous étiez on
peut se demander si vous n'avez pas été
tenté de craquer nous en savons
d'ailleurs un peu quelque chose
expliquez-nous ce qui s'est passé et si
vous avez tenir d'ailleurs déjà ce qui
m'a fait tenir c'est julien j'étais
enceinte donc je veux dire après la mort
de grégory jarry j'arrive et avait rien
qui pouvait qu'arriver à me remonter mon
jean marie était près de moi et tout
mais je veux dire je me suis santé
consommerait donc une fois que je me
suis retrouvée enceinte
là j'ai repris des forces
j'aime bien donner la vie et tout je
veux dire ça s'est fait automatiquement
puis après une fois que jean marie donc
est allé en prison
là il ya une très grande coupure c'était
c'était dur c'était ma et là il a fallu
que je me batte pour lui ce que je ne
voulais surtout pas qu'il soit jugé
qu'ils soient condamnés sur le doute il
fallait que la vérité sur grégory sort
pour que jean marie aussi s'en sont donc
automatiquement
pour jean-marie pour grégory pour la
vérité pour grégory mais pour julien
qu'on attendait il fallait tenir jeudi
y'avait pas un pas d'autres moyens et
c'est venu automatiquement et puis ce
qui m'a fait tenir aussi c'est
jean-marie départ noir je viens nous
visitent ensemble à la prison à savoir
denis ça me donnait des franciliens
l'étonnante correspondance que vous
n'avez cessé de vous échangez d'ailleurs
qui sont des lettres d'un très grand
amour d'une très forte union en tout cas
visiblement si l'on en croit au pied de
la lettre ce que vous avez écrit c'est
on voit bien que c'est un lien oui ce
que je voulais dire c'est que avant
qu'on nous assassine grégory on était un
coup plus on sait penser mais il n'y
avait pas de problème je n'y a pas de
nuages avait pas de problème et il nous
arrivait nous est tombé ça sur la tête
comme on pourrait dire nous appuient
notre enfant on avait faim de toute
notre vie autour de lui donc je vais
dire l'amour qu'on avait là pour l'autre
par la douleur il encore et c'est encore
plus soudés on sait en plus on nous
donnait des coups plus notre amour
automatiquement grandissait plus la
pression était forte à l'extérieur plus
ça vous arrange ans est dans votre
identité et madame est ce qu'il est
exact qu'il ya eu des moments
vous étiez tellement désespérée que vous
avez tenté de craquer vraiment c'est bon
le temps d'en de l'anc est donc du juge
lambert je voyais bien tout ce qui se
passait autour de moi un pic il est
influençable depuis que les enquêteurs
mais je me disais il ya des hauts
magistrats au dessus il y avait quand
même derrière le juge lambert il ya
trois ou magistrat à la cour de
cassation deux géants sa chance de
cassation de nancy l'accusation de nancy
je confonds éculés dessus donc
j'espérais qu'au moins un regard de
trois magistrats sur le dossier
il est vrai quand même que quelques nra
qui ils se sont trompés et lille on
était à côté
mais quand ils m'ont renvoyé aux assises
je veux dire là pour moi c'était fini je
veux dire jean marie était en prison
j'avais plus grégory on allait mettre en
prison pour je ne sais combien d'années
parce que les acides et où rien peut pas
dire que mon en ressort d'un procès
d'assises donc je voyais qu'on était
construit par séparer des années c'est
là que j'ai fait ma tentative de susi je
voudrais vous poser une autre question
madame est vraiment al'inverse ainsi qu
à vous monsieur quand avez vous commencé
à reprendre confiance dans la justice
quand ou à la lumière de quoi comme vous
voulez vous en prie
ben moi j'ai été en c était en juin 87
la première fois que j'ai vu
monsieur président simon c'est à dire
l'âge et de la première fois j'ai vu un
homme qui me parlait en respectant la
douleur jamais nous là on a un respect
kanu douleur est là quand il m'a dit
qu'il ferait tout tout ce qui est en son
pouvoir pour vous faire la vérité
j'avais vu un homme vraiment prêt à tout
faire
c'était pas que des paroles c'était dans
le regard aussi et là j'ai repris
confiance
pourquoi utilisez-vous souvent le mot
non seulement pour le livre que vous
avez fait mais pour tout l'anc est qu'à
reprise absolument minutieusement le jeu
ciment pourquoi utilisez-vous souvent le
mot de thérapie est ce parce qu'en effet
il fallait faire deux choses
c'est-à-dire renseigner donner les
informations les plus précises sur votre
comportement les uns les autres et
d'autre part sortir de vous cette
douleur dont vous parlez ce qui s'est
passé après avoir vécu ça c'était
difficile de s'exprimer librement et
surtout quand on a vécu ce qu'on a vécu
est là le président si mozilla travaille
et il a complètement vidé jamais on nous
avait posé deux couples de questions au
pardon sur le couple jamais vous avez
posé des questions sur grégory comment
vivaient et là c'est la première chose
qu'il a fait le président simon
donc on s'est complètement vidé chose
qu'on n'avait pas fait et en même temps
un espoir de justice madame puisque
j'aurai aussi en rajouter c'est que et
nous laissait parler devant nous on
avait un magistrat nous poser une
question mais il ne coupait pas il
cherchait pas à vouloir en dire
à nous faire comprendre non vous mentez
ou chercher ce qu'il fallait pas à côté
de nous laisser parler y noter structure
scrupuleusement tous que on lui disait
et où je dire avec lui en slip et ray on
avait pris les auditions étaient très
longues l'épée vélo par exemple les pv
avec monsieur lambert fait des trois
pages avec le président simon au minimum
ses trente pages donc vous avez tout de
suite l'idée que voulez vous dire
exactement quand vous dites que vous
avez le sentiment d'avoir eu affaire à
deux types de justice deux types de
justice
en fait l'image que se donne un mois
l'image que je me donne de la justice
des magistrats comme monsieur simon
comme monsieur martin comme ceux qu'on a
rencontrés après monsieur non mais je ne
pensais pas qu'on puisse rencontrer une
justice comme un final et c'était
d'autant plus je le prenais d'autant
plus mal parce que je me rendais compte
voici des fêtes et vous ce que vous avez
vécu madame et vous monsieur
un site chacun d'entre nous tous a
beaucoup de relativité de retour sur ce
qui se passe lorsque nous travaillons
même si l'on aurait pu ajouter un
certain nombre de journaux radios dans
les titres de presse que vous nous
revoir et peut-être même si c'est d'une
façon moindre quelques jours nos
documents télévision bref ce n'est pas à
nous de donner la leçon est en tout cas
ce serait moi même ce soir bien mal
placé pour dire quoi que ce soit dans ce
sens je vais donc reprendre le cours de
mon questionnement si vous le voulez
bien
d'abord est-ce que vous vous souvenez de
votre première rencontre avec les
journalistes
ma première rencontre avec un
journaliste un journaliste de radio je
lui avais dit comme ça ça devait être le
surlendemain je lui avais dit comme ça
si c'est celui qui a téléphoné je crois
savoir qui c'est et sur les ondes on a
passé je sais qui c'est déjà la une ont
été trompés et vous madame
je crois que la première fois que jean
marie et l'envoyer parlé mais moi je
reste toujours en retrait c'était au
moment
après les après la première
confrontation avec
mes collègues de travail au mois de
novembre vraiment l'ag a fallu que je
parle toujours se justifier toujours
répéter toujours les mêmes questions que
jugement mais repoussé dans ses pieds
mais ce à partir de là que je crois que
j'ai vraiment parler avec des
journalistes romands bon je les voyais
mais je ne leur parlais pas il ya eu des
centaines et des centaines probablement
plus d'un millier d'articles ou de
reportages qui vous ont été consacrés
encore une fois presse écrite radio et
même télévision
pourquoi selon vous tant de presse dans
ce petit village des vosges
jusqu'aujourd'hui de dix ans plus tard
vous avez compris ce qui s'était passé
on se dit qu'à l'époque il avait ce
probablement rien à se mettre sous la
dent comme on dit est peut-être un peu
courts s'annonce non mais ya pas que ça
à pied le côté aussi du corbeau je pense
que le corbeau qui qui qui mais moi je
veux dire qui
qui revendique le crime sachant qu'il y
avait eu un corbeau pendant deux années
précédentes
donc tout ça a fait que pour eux c'était
cité du blues au franchement sincèrement
avant ce qui vous est arrivé ce qu'il
vous arrive est de lire la presse
régulièrement ou de temps en temps est
ce que vous étiez d'électeurs à ses
fidèles de faits divers ou pas du tout
pas du tout on acheté aucune presse mais
je regardais même pas les
les informations télévisées ni la radio
aucune presse ni magazine
donc on verra tout à l'heure d'ailleurs
ce qu'il en est aujourd'hui
tous les journalistes n'avaient pas le
même comportement avec vous quelles
étaient ses différents comportements
il y avait deux poules on dit qu'on lui
et s'était dit pendant le reportage
avait les pros villemin et les pros la
roche mais seulement le pôle les
provillois ils n'étaient pas très
nombreux et avaient je crois 5-6 que
l'on voyait notamment de paris match et
c'est tout comme enfin jean s était pour
nous dire bon ton monte en même temps
c'était pas exclue spécialement pour
avoir une exclusivité quoi par contre
d'autrui d'autres poussées est ce que
vous aviez déjà rencontré un journaliste
et discuter avec lui avant la mort de
votre enfant non jamais je ne savais pas
ce que c'est vraiment vous avez beaucoup
appris beaucoup oui madame
oui je pensais quand même que c'était
des jambons qui faisait leur travail
mais enfin qui respecte est un peul et
les autres personnes mais tout ce que à
part les cinq qu'on voyait régulièrement
toutes les tous les autres ils ont une
façon de d'écraser pour avoir leur eux
leurs informations
qu'est ce qui vous a le plus choqué vous
bougiez c'est plutôt les images que j'ai
vues après parce que le jour de
l'enterrement grégori g j'ai pas vu tout
ça mais j'étais dans le noir complet
mais après quand j'ai vu il monte sur
les tombes ils respectent oria je veux
dire il faut au moins avoir un peu d'eux
qu'ils fassent leur travail mais au
moins qu'ils respectent un peu
les cimetières ou d'autres endroits
c'est pour ça a été vraiment une
prolifération cancéreuse a appris des
inquiétudes que personne n'a pu
contrôler pour finir parce que
maintenant ces décharges vis-à-vis des
rédacteurs en chef c'est vrai ce que
disait le sergio diaz carr dans le
document
mais je pense aussi que c'est une
question de morale de chacun on n'a pas
le droit de dire n'importe quoi comme ça
ne serait-ce que d'avoir une carte de
journaliste non est-ce que vous avez
commis vous même des erreurs avec les
journalistes
oui moi j'en ai commis lesquels 20 cas
d'erreur du moins une balle simplement
de vouloir répondre aux rumeurs
dès l'instant vous répondez aux rumeurs
c'est la peste et puis bon ça ne
s'arrête pas à quoi bellamy demain mais
moi tout toutes les erreurs enfin c'est
pas que j'ai fait c'est qu'on m'a fait
faire entre guillemets c'est d'avoir
posé répondu aux interviews faire le
livre qu'on m'a fait faire en 86 alors
que j'étais pas d'accord je me dis tout
ça si j'avais eu la force de dire non et
vous si vous aviez su à quoi vous à quoi
ça pouvait vous entraîner dans certains
cas de dérapage que ça voulait dire moi
j'étais en prison et quand on me prouvez
le et parler du projet du livre de
certaines exclusivités
je disais vas-y puisque les gens verront
qu'on peut tuer en fait et puis nous ça
va nous donner les moyens de nous
défendre mais au contraire c'est ce qui
nous a en partie en français est ce que
vous avez eu besoin des journalistes
pour vous informer notamment dans
certaines sur certaines pièces du
dossier et par ailleurs j'aimerais qu'on
parle d'ordre un instant de ces photos
et/ou et oui interview qui ont été
vendus en exclusivité c'est le moment ou
jamais de vous expliquer puisque vous
publié dans votre livre vos comptes
financiers personnels alors d'avoir est
ce que vous avez eu besoin des
journalistes au début on savait rien du
tout l'une des rondes étaient même une
fois connecté au camp s'est porté partie
civile on ne savait rien du loustic donc
parfois ils vous ont informé sur ce
qu'il pensait vous savez être l'état du
dossier
mais oui tout à fait on était partie
civile mais on n'avait pas du tout accès
au dossier puisque mes gars où on n'a
pas l'habitude de mener des procès
verbaux et manou et en partie civile
et moi je me suis servi par exemple
commune s'est servi de moi un
journaliste de chez paris match qui m'a
porté les documents qu'il avait récupéré
chez un avocat qui me faisait écouter
notamment les déclarations de muriel et
puis d'autres est-ce que vous avez
touché de l'argent je crois que c'est
oui maintenant le sait est ce qu'on peut
dire la réalité exacte de ces photos ou
de cette interview de ses interviews je
ne sais pas exactement et vous allez
nous le dire qu'ils ont donné lieu à des
exclusivités et d'ailleurs à quoi a
servi cet argent si vous me permettez de
vous le demander
oui ben comme je me suis occupé des
comptes mondial depuis je suis sorti le
en 87 et je me suis rendu compte que bon
il ya eu désigne la première exclusivité
qui a eu il ya eu de l'argent
c'était à travers la naissance de julien
mais c'était une transaction s'était pas
une exclusivité puisque on avait fait un
procès contre match emma je préfère
avoir
régler à l'amiable si vous voulez que
d'avoir un mauvais procès mais tout en
ayant une exclusivité
donc il ya eu ces photos et médias ou
travaillé depuis près d'un an
oui et il nous avait rien demandé sinon
7000 francs
et puis bon il y avait là celui la
situation avait bien changé et on était
partie civile
là un an après nous étions tous les deux
inculpés donc les propos le travail la
procédure était complètement différent
et voilà des faux nez pour les premiers
déficits et c'était la naissance de
julien est ce que vous savez au total
vous avez en mémoire enfin j'imagine que
oui
au total combien d'argent a été changé
entre la presse et vous et vous nous
direz aussi si donc ce qu'il est advenu
de cet argent sert qui a servi
visiblement à payer les avocats ou les
dommages intérêts adoma les dommages
intérêts mais il faut savoir quand même
que pour nous défendre contre la presse
surtout contrôler et la justice ça nous
a coûté près de 17 de ses petits 7000
francs pardon par mois mais c'est quand
même énorme
sauf quand vous ne disposez pas quand
vous revenez pas du tout quand bien
combien gagnez-vous à l'époque à
l'époque je gagnais 8000 francs par mois
mais bon j'étais centre à main et
j'étais en prison et steene étaient sans
travail avait plus de revenus sinon la
location
parent isolé qui est de 3000 francs à
peu près mais dix sept mille francs pour
se défendre à travers toutes les
procédures que nous avons fait les
exclusivités et les procédures je crois
actuellement qu'on en a à peu près une
soixantaine notamment il y en a pas mal
qui sont déboutés et nous il nous est
revenu à nous personnellement sur toutes
les procédures sur neuf ans 6500 francs
par mois ce qui nous a permis je dirais
il faut pas non plus je dirais cracher
comme ça sur la grille nous a permis de
survivre mais le gard où ce qu'il a fait
ça nous a permis de s'ouvrir
parce que s'il n'y avait pas eu ces
exclusivités il faut savoir que même en
faisant des procès contre les médias qui
ont débordé ça ne remboursaient même pas
les frais la justice vous a présenté des
excuses
est ce que certains journalistes autre
que la rédaction du parisien qu on a vu
tout à l'heure
l'ont fait il ya eu zizou acquis qu'il a
fait au cours de mon procès au sujet des
photos qu'il avait fait sur avec les
joies sur la tombe
oui ce qui est qu'est ce qu'elle était
un montage et c'est tout et le parisien
c'est tout c'est tout madame il m'a
serré ne réagit pas lu ses excuses
personnellement de gilles ouaki
puisqu'il les un faux procès à la barre
et moi j'étais pas j'avais pas loin
d'être encore votre non-lieu madame
villemin at il eu à vos yeux le même
retentissement que votre inculpation non
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire à ce
sujet que quand déjà pour vous sans
parler des médias mais au niveau juge
judiciaire
je n'arrive pas à comprendre bon ça
c'est mon opinion personnelle que quand
on a qu'une personne
donc on vous emmène au tribunal on vous
amène dans le bureau du juge il ya toute
la presse qui suit par contre quand on
vous donne un non lieu
on n'a pas besoin de vous on envoie le
non lieu par la poste et puis voilà je
trouve que c'est pas normal mais pour
toute affaire j on devrait devant le
juge que le juge nous lisent aussi bien
le non lieu comme quand il nous a lu
l'acte d'accusation
déjà ça et au niveau de la presse a pas
été ça pas été du tout un retentissant
non 23 articles pour le non lieu
et au total je crois que c'était pas de
2000 articles en passant de
l'inculpation de christine donc c'est
assez considérable depuis que votre
visage banal villemin a fait ce qu'on
appelle la une en terme
de mul des métiers journalistique est ce
que vous supportez encore votre image de
vous voir devant votre photo où donc est
pourquoi je ne supporte plus déjà ses
devoirs des nouvelles têtes jeu que bon
me regarde toujours l'impression qu'on
me regarde en se posant des questions en
disant oui mais c'est elle avec accusés
je veux dire la christine villemin que
la justice a fait et après vous aussi
les médias non je ne pense que ce n'est
pas moi dire je me suis retrouvé avec
toutes ces boues en pleine figure
pendant pendant des années j'ai
je ne supporte plus plus au visage
quand je me vois donc j'ai tout de suite
cette image tout ce qui a eu toutes ses
amis et tout ça c'est difficile bon ça
va
j'espère que ça reviendra que justice
ait presse sont des piliers
indispensables dans une démocratie
est-ce que vous en êtes d'accord je dis
oui à condition que cela se respecte et
je ne parle pas de règles ou de loi mais
que vous avez je parle au niveau des
métiers aller au niveau des médias il ya
une déontologie quoiqu'elles soient
respectés à ce moment là qu'est une
commission qui serait sympa et vous
madame ben moi un bon justice 8 mais
enfin qui faut aussi que des juges des
bons magistrale que si on tente sur un
juge qui qui fait qu'ils enquêtent sur
une enquête mais qu'à charge qui veut
pas chercher plus loin
là je ne suis pas je dis que ça c'est
pas une justice faut qu'il est bon
magistrat qui qui se laisse pas
influencer par la presse qui n'est qui
évite au moins le moins possible les
journalistes et puis les médias il en
faut mais en fait ils devraient plus plu
sera arrêté de faire des noirs à tout
prix faire d une avec le malheur des
gens bons qu'ils disent les faits mais
qui n'a qu'ils arrêtent de broder
surtout surtout les faits qui se passe
je n'ai fait c'est tout ce qui est
autour qui est malsain je n'ai personne
à défendre de même que je n'ai pas de
leçon à donner
je vais quand même vous poser une
question madame est ce que vous n'avez
pas le sentiment que à travers la presse
et parfois certains dérapages et dieu
sait que vous avez été victime vous d'un
certain dérapage il y à aussi la
curiosité d'un certain public qui au
fond donnent une sorte de fausse
légitimité à s'attaquer à cette attitude
est ce que vous allez plus loin que la
presse c'est sûr si les gens nés tous
les matins n'allait pas au kiosque à
journaux pour acheter tout ce qui est ce
qui va et ce qui est souvent je pense
que les gens d'aller se calmerait aussi
un peu si les gens montrait qu' un
ras-le-bol qu'il faut que la presse
commence à être plus
plus sereine qu'elle fasse pas tant de
sensationnel peut-être que ça marche
vraiment vous vous rendez compte qu'à ce
qui nous concerne la veille de
l'inculpation de christine monsieur
lambert a eu la visite d'un homme du
dossier 1
on sait pas si c'est un policier un
avocat ou ou autre qui lui a dit si tu
l'inculper ou pas mais les médias votre
cas c'est donc vous rendez compte
je crève l'abcès je lève l'hypothèque ça
veut dire quoi ce sont les paroles de
jeu n'est pas hors du jeu ça veut dire
quoi ça c'est là où ça prend des
proportions si vous tombez la pression
mais si vous tombez avec des gens qui
sont qui sont fragilisés pour finir dans
un métier comme celui ci qui est dur je
dis non là c'est pas non tout à l'heure
je vous ai demandé si avant la mort de
votre enfant vous lisez la presse vous
avez dit non vous étiez hors de ce monde
je vais maintenant vous reposez la même
question est-ce que depuis ou l'alizé
alors depuis on achète bien sûr parce
que on sent obligé que quand ces titres
et sion nous quand ça vous concerne
ah oui parce qu en garde voilà vérifier
puis s'il va encore trop loin de nouveau
les diffamations et ou sinon je n'achète
pas de presse je ne j'ai vite au plus
les informations je veux dire on a
tellement épris été pris dans cette
spirale que je veux dire que j'écoute
les informations télévisées ou la radio
ou les uns après les fientes
oui je me dis bon ils disent ça mais est
ce que c est ce que c'est vrai moi je
pense le contraire après mais ça va
tellement loin il ya pas très longtemps
je ne citerai pas le jour le 7 m dos et
un hebdomadaire qui titrait jean marie
villemin
condamné à trois ans l'attend en dépit
de jean marie villemin
vous regardez en dessous c'était écrit
bourdeau vous regarder à l'intérieur
c'est un type qui se passait pour mon
cousin
je regrette il aurait fallu que mon père
est un frère pour grand cousin jean
marie villemin en gros de là dessus
est-ce que vous avez usé de votre droit
de réponse de remise en ordre de votre
propre identité dans cette affaire par
rapport à l'hebdomadaire que vous citez
n'ont pas du tout on laisse nos
maintenant on a décidé depuis sphère
d'action ça fait déjà un certain temps
ça nous coûte plus qu'autre chose ils
sont on est débouté
mais en même temps je comprends aussi
que par rapport à l'opposition de
demander justice pour préjudice
diffamant quand on sait par rapport à
mon geste je comprends que ça soit aussi
peut être déplacée par vis-à-vis des
magistrats à paris
donc on porte trop long on arrête le
votre geste c'est à dire l'homme qui
avait un fusil en main et voilà et puis
qu'aujourd'hui l'économie
voilà mais seulement c'est l'homme qui
est de 85 ne faut pas vu quoi encore
quelque chose est ce que vous allez
apprendre à vos enfants à discerner et
comment le fait de vous d'ailleurs déjà
par rapport à julien pech qui moulinent
est un peu petit et qu'il était en âge
de comprendre mieux a déjà tout dit
depuis 16 octobre il y avait pas été
totalement tout ce qui s'est passé pour
mon chef me envie d'appeler petit à
petit s'est passé il a seulement su en
février 93 que j'avais fait onze jours
de prison je ne sais pas facile à dire à
un enfant il faut il faut y aller
doucement et puis il voir comment il le
prend et puis on attendait surtout
qu'ils nous posent des questions qui
n'ont qu'à chaque fois qu'il nous poser
des questions disait plus est ce qu'on
va déjà
c'est apprendre c'est surtout de de ne
pas porter de jugement vis-à-vis de la
presse ou de la rumeur qu'aucun innocent
peut être viser surtout ça et puis qu'il
soit bon et tolérant parce que dans le
monde que l'on vire on s'imaginait pas à
quoi
mais faites votre vie privée a été très
largement exposée dans les médias comme
on vient de le voir là est ce que vous
avez pu reconstruire une vie privée
d'abord est-ce que c'était votre vie
privée ou au fond quelque chose qui a
fini par être artificiel et faux par
rapport à vous ou en partie faux en un
an quand on s'est retrouvé en fin
décembre 87 on n'avait pas besoin de
reconstruire une eau de vie privée
puisque la vie privée des caves été mis
dans la presse les gens le couple jean
marie et christine villemin s'était pas
nous jeudi à nous quand on lisait sale
impression de voir d'autres personnes
donc nous de vie privée continuez comme
elles s'étaient arrêtées avant que 580
que ça qui avant 84
je voudrais pour la dernière partie que
nous allons passer ensemble madame et
monsieur je voudrais que vous proposez
que nous parlons maintenant
d'aujourd'hui et de l'avenir si vous
voulez bien vous avez d'abord quitter
vos racines vosgienne pourquoi ou lauren
baptisons qu'on le regrette beaucoup
donc c'est sûr que ce n'est plus
possible pour nous d'aller vivre dans
les vosges mais les médias ont tellement
sa ligne rouge que bon ça nous faisait
mal parce qu'on était heureux là bas
c'est un boss c'est un beau département
c'est une belle région
on a fait passer les gens là-bas pour
demeurer c'est faux c'est pas c'est
parce qu'ils étaient 10 mai
pardonnez moi je vais vous interrompre
un instant vous dites les médias en
selle et les vosges
est-ce que vous ne trouvez pas que le
crime dont a été victime votre fils
relève de quelque chose aussi d'un autre
temps de quelque chose de sentiments
humains ce qui c'est incroyable moi je
prends ce qui s'est passé avec céline
dans le var c'est aussi pire c'est à
dire rien comme et j'imagine que les
habitants du var ont la même attitude
vis-à-vis de ce que la presse a eu
exactement on n'a pas attendu ce qu'on a
entendu sous les vosges pour le voir
quand même vous pensez qu'il ya une
différence bien une différence tout à
fait pardon nous avoir un temps que les
a pris et puis pour ce qui est
maintenant de vivre dans la région
parisienne ça c'est fait parce que mon
employeur n'ont pas trop on ne m'a
jamais abandonné je n'ai jamais utilisé
foncier donc c'est une mutation et au
moment de la mise en liberté
il y avait une condition principal
c'était de ne pas pouvoir se réinstaller
un niveau rouge donc mon patron m'a
proposé un travail dans la région
parisienne
c'est comme ça que nous sommes arrivés à
réjean président
d'une certaine manière vous êtes content
d'être fondus dans un anonyme un peu
plus discret et de ne plus être dans
lorraine
d'une certaine manière ou est-ce que ça
vous manque vraiment
ça nous manque mais bon on est dans une
région qui est très belle aussi à la
région de l'essonne où on est je
voudrais pas quand même y retourner n'a
pas moi je vais bien le juge notre
souffert de grégory tous qui a eu après
je veux dire non après la mort de
grégory c'était sûr qu'on partirait à
quoi ça sert mais je parle avant quoi
bonheur nous avons connu nous étions
bien dans les vosges
comment vivez-vous aujourd'hui monsieur
vilma vous travaillez vous avez repris
donc on a compris à l'instant que vous
avez repris votre travail vous avez
vous étiez contremaître vous avez
retrouvé un poste identique ou bien vous
avez pris un autre travail s'est passé
pas le même travail c'est un travail de
technicien je travaille dans la face à
vous ça va rien vous dire dans les
demandes qui à prendre dans les mousses
de polyuréthane sièges automobiles voilà
c'est à dire un équipementier si vous
voulez point du travail c'est beaucoup
plus intéressant pour moi aujourd'hui
que à l'époque oui et vous madame vous
ne travaillez pas non je suis je reste à
la maison puis j'élève nous deux ans
enfin je laime je m'occupe de la maison
et demi d'enfants du jeu de julien et de
la petite emeline quand votre vie est
elle redevenue porteuse d'avenir
porteuse d'espoir vers quel moment parce
que vous avez été enfermé dans une
tornade effrayante
à quel moment je parle du point de vue
mme du point de vue finale parce que bon
il ya eu plusieurs moments d'espoir il
ya eu des moments d'espoir où le
président enseignements on voyait qu'ils
avançaient les tessinois d'aboutir parce
que bon on vraiment en dernier
c'était vraiment sérieux est bon il a eu
son accident cardiaque et là à ce moment
là c'est vrai qu'on a perdu confiance et
après on me
président monsieur martin a repris
l'instruction il retrouvait de nouveau
témoignage elles en avaient repris
espoir nouveau procès du puy bon une
fois qu'il ya eu le non lieu à ce
moment-là c'est une libération
judiciaire mais mais mais médiatiquement
non comment vivez vous dans votre
village par rapport aux habitants par
rapport aux enfants à l'école est ce que
tout se passe bien ce que ces femmes et
ces hommes ont été très accueillants
très gentil où est-ce qu'ils étaient
méfiants vis-à-vis de vous parce que
c'est un endroit qui al'air discret et
agréable et modeste 13 axes de papou oui
mais tu dernier légion comment puisque
jean-marie il va beaucoup moins que moi
je vais faire les courses et tout amener
les enfants à l'école
je veux dire il ya tout de suite eu ya
pas une curiosité je vous dis c'était
j'ai tout de suite été bien si j'avais
dans un magasin je rentrais je disais
bonjour
jamais on a une personne n'a osé ne pas
me répondait même bonjour mais vraiment
en douceur comme en cachette comme
disait bonjour ma vie de ma personne n'a
jamais eu ce geste de recul envers moi
et les mamans de l'école et tout on nous
a toujours bien
bien acceptée on m'a toujours bien
parler n'y a jamais eu de mauvaises
paroles ou mauvais regard et vous
monsieur le maire on a trouvé un
équilibre
on est logés bon l'employeur on n'a pas
de vision hlm donc déjà là à partir de
là on revit et au niveau travail cgt
deux ans à peu près à retrouver un
certain équilibre où je faisais mon
travail je disais pas grand chose
et puis depuis qu'on a eu et méline 1,90
à en a retrouvé mon équilibre
la vie est redevenue un vrai projet re
devenu un vrai projet parce que mon
julien on s'était passé français
accroché à lui c'était notre ça a été
notre sauveur c'est peut-être lourd à
dire mais c'est vrai les mêmes julien
pour finir la trouver une certaine
liberté
ce qu'on était trop a prévu plus son jeu
dire bon c'est pas bien de dire ça de
bon dans les moments là quand on a voulu
julien on voulait pas du tout entendre
parler autour de nous on remplace pas un
enfant par un autre et c'est vrai que
l'on dit non on a besoin d'un enfant et
tout et c'est vrai qu'avec les années
jusque quatre ans parce qu'au delà je
connaissais pas ce que j'en retiens
qu'un enfant de 4 ans je veux dire tous
les mois tous les ans on recherche les
gestes les habitudes de l'enfant qu'on a
perdu au delà de quatre ans après il me
lit n'est venu donc je veux dire julien
il a pu vivre sa vie nuit entièrement
julien il a pu faire ce qu'ils voulaient
sans que que je cherche à retrouver des
jets et il a eu plus de liberté parce
qu'après il ya eu les mots line donc n a
vraiment donné personnellement m'a donné
mon équilibre
vous pensez
monsieur et madame villemin qu'un lourd
secret dans votre famille au niveau de
la génération qui vous a précédé a
probablement gâché votre vie est ce que
vous avez vous même des secrets pour vos
enfants n'ont aucun secret non puisqu'on
vient on a dit julien il connaît tous
depuis des lieux jusqu'à jusqu'au procès
le plus petit soit il il est toujours
mauvais d'apprendre des mauvaises
nouvelles quand vous a caché pendant des
années nos noms seraient alors on à
emeline donc l ac 3 ans et là on refait
le même chemin qu'on a fait avec julien
donc déjà environ
on lui a montré la différence entre la
photo de julian grégory parce qu'elle
appelait tous les deux c'était julien
maintenant là c'est grégory donc on
commence à lui habitué pour pas non plus
quelle est sa portée sur elle et qu'elle
sache tout et en parlant ce soir
publiquement il ya deux aspects il ya un
positif le négatif je vous poserai une
question tout à l'heure est ce que vous
faites d'une certaine manière un cadeau
entre guillemets à vos enfants en
restaurant publiquement la place de
votre nom qu'il porte aussi est ce que
c'est ça que vous voulez faire tout ce
qu'on lui sait ce qu'on veut c'est que
ça soit pas à eux qui quand on
disparaîtra qui se bat comme on en voit
beaucoup dans d'autres affaires qui se
battent pour réhabiliter l'honneur de
l'honneur de leur part en l'honneur de
leur maman est ce que je veux dire jean
marie injustice est prononcée et tout
mais moi bon on est tous c'est tout à
fait différent ce qui aurait ce qu'on a
vécu judiciairement l'écurie n'est pas
se battre pour réhabiliter l'honneur de
sa maman monsieur villemin tout à fait
c'est allah te dis c'est à dire que l'on
veut que leurs enfants vivent leur vie
et qu'ils aient le moindre difficulté
possible de porter le nom vima mulak
pourquoi avez vous y at il d'autres
raisons que celles que vous veillez
d'exprimer pour lesquelles vous avez
souhaité vous remettre sous les regards
d'une part en écrive un livre de vos
propres conversation ou échange de
lettres des années de prison et puis
d'une autre part en venant dans cette
émission dont vous nous avez dit que ce
serait le seul endroit vous voudriez
parler que vous vous arrêteriez après
pourquoi avez vous accepté va pas
accepter puisque c'est vous qui l'avez
souhaité mais pourquoi avez vous lu ça
avait voulu ça parce que d'une certaine
manière vous ressortez de l'anonymat
qu'il risque de vous nuire à nouveau oui
mais est-ce que depuis 8 ans 9 ans
j'étais heureux le public a entendu
parler nous mais de tout et n'importe
quoi je dirais ils ont une certaine
image de du couple jean marie vie miles
une certaine image de moi que je voulais
faire halte là quoi maintenant
laissez-nous on est con venez montrer
aux gens qu'on est comme tout le monde
ce qui nous est arrivé
ça peut arriver à tout le monde que les
médias s'acharnent sur nous la justice
et que connaît des gens simples que puis
vont ya le fait aussi qui se passent pas
le dis dans le livre se passe pas un
mois cinq y est pas un journal ou une
radio porte qui l'on parle de nous on
nous salissent et puis bon il est bien
est ce que je disais au départ s'il ya
un besoin aussi de vouloir se libérer
parce que je reconnais mon geste je
l'assumé c'est vrai et je vous dis c'est
lourd à porter contre avons
contrairement c'est pas accessoire comme
on peut y en a qu'on peut le dire c'est
pas du tout
avant j'aimais avant avant avant l'amour
de mon enfant j'étais c'était
contre la mort de qui que ce soit je dis
ça me ferait énormément cancun quand
j'ai appris quand vous êtes à vif
et puis qu'on vous pousse comme ça dans
un étonnant parce que c'est ce qui s'est
passé et puis c'est pas que les médias
c'est ce sont des aveugles attitude
d'avocats de magistrats qui est bien
ressorti au cours du procès sans s'en
est bien rendu compte mais seulement la
responsabilité la co responsabilité
collective
je me suis j'aime rey jean marie et
christine villemin maître du positif
dans cette sphère entretien quand tout
ça sera fini quand vous aurez vous serez
libéré de tout ce que vous avez à payer
au titre des dommages-intérêts ou autres
frais de procédure quelle vie voudriez
vous à voir demain à quoi aspirez-vous
vraiment mais moi ce que j'espère c'est
que qu'on puisse fêter nos noces d'or
être entouré de mes enfants de mes
petits enfants de mes arrières enfants
et je crois que ça sera déjà pas mal
et vous monsieur déjà ça ça serait déjà
un beau cadeau mais déjà je dois payer
la condamnation la première condamnation
je peux vous dire qu'elle était réglé
donc c'est déjà un point c'est grâce aux
avant ceux du livre de droits d'auteur
et par rapport aux saisies de mon
salaire saisie des comptes personnels
allocations des enfants mais bon là
c'est fait la première condamnation
réglé après j'attends une prochaine
condamnation qui est un sursis à statuer
qui est sûr le régime patrimoniaux et
puis là je vais rejouer pas mais vu ce
week
après on espère trouver un certain
anonymat quoi est-ce que les jours vous
serez libre de vos mouvements vis-à-vis
de la justice vis-à-vis de vos enfants
qui peut-être on grandit ou même avec
eux s'ils ne sont pas encore le vent est
ce que vous aspirez à les vivre hors de
france loin pour retrouver à la base un
anonymat total c'est à dire au fond dans
un milieu qui ne connaîtraient même pas
votre nom ça vous a vu cette tentation
on l'a eue on l'a séparé crips on sait
pas trop ce que parce que mon autre pays
on aime bien et on sait ce qu'on se
disait n'y a pas très longtemps cette
saison c'est un des plus beaux d'après
ce qu'on entend dire parce que nous on
n'est pas beaucoup voyagé mais
mais en même temps on a tellement
souffert dans ce pays qu'il a envie de
partir ça c'est sûr est ce
qu'aujourd'hui dix ans après ses
douleurs 10 ans et 9 ans après ses
douleurs cdc de morts ces deuils cette
façon que des institutions dans ce
qu'elles ont eu parfois d'excessif
on tue de s'emparer de vous est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment d'avoir changé
intellectuellement et culturellement jeu
je dirais qu'on a mûri forcément
intellectuellement aussi culturellement
je ne pense pas parce que je ne pense
pas le fait d'avoir repris ce que moi ça
comment ça se passe au niveau de la
justice un mois pour quelque chose
je ne pense pas peut-être qu'à l'époque
si j'avais reçu avant je remonte
peut-être aidé mais maintenant je pense
qu'il est trop tard et vous madame je
pense que ça nous a beaucoup apporté
beaucoup de tolérance surtout lapointe
je vous remercie madame villemin et je
vous remercie vous monsieur villemin
d'avoir répondu très franchement et on
imagine du fond du coeur aux questions
que
auquel vous vous êtes exposés en
souhaitant venir dans cette émission ou
en effet nous étions tout à fait content
de vous accueillir pour entendre votre
propos puisqu'on est en effet celui là
il n'est maquillés par aucune forme
d'intermédiaire ce qui vous ai dit ce
soir a été dit par vous s'ils sont
suivait quelque chose qui se vouent soit
désagréable c'est une responsabilité que
vous avez souhaité prendre et est en
tout cas qu'il faudrait porter je
voudrais vous remercier pour cela je
rappellerai et je citerai un seul livre
qui et les cris de vos conversations
croisés et qui s'appelle le 16 octobre
qui est la date de la mort de votre
petit grégory c'était en 1984 et je
voudrais remercier deux personnes qui
nous ont aidés à préparer dignement
cette émission qui est monsieur laurent
beccaria qui a été votre éditeur aux
éditions plon et notre ancienne consoeur
mademoiselle laurence lacour et je vous
remercie de vous être déplacés sans
aucune forme de fard ni je dirais de
maquillage de votre propre état d'esprit
bonne fin de soirée à vous merci de nous
avoir suivi une autre marche du siècle
la semaine prochaine
[Musique]